John Tucker was once described by the
Chicago Tribune as one of Chicago's
finest and most idiosyncratic trial
lawyers next he shares experiences from
his life in the courtroom from his book
trial and error this is just over half
an hour
I'd like to welcome everyone here today
and we see some friends and some family
here and thank you very much all of you
for coming to the bookstall at chestnut
court John Tucker has been here before
he is part of our family and he has
written a wonderful book called trial
and error the education of a courtroom
lawyer John Tucker is a famous name in
the legal field the Chicago Tribune
called him a fine and idiosyncratic
trial lawyer I'd like to know what
indios and Craddock means and I hope
you'll explain that well I think it has
a ring to it so anyway without further
ado I'm so pleased that John is here
tonight and will tell us about his new
book and his career thank you
Thank You Roberta I do want to thank
Roberta and the and the bookstall at
chestnut court for having me and my
sister Patty who has been a member of
the family of this bookstore for many
many years and probably had to twist
Roberta's arm to get me back here but
she did a good job take a little bit of
water first trial and error the
education of a courtroom lawyer well I
think that it is of course another trial
lawyers memoir and I think that that is
probably the most baleful of all genres
in contemporary American literature
every lawyer thinks they ought to write
a memoir a surprising number of them get
published and almost all of them are
either very poorly written or boring
frequently both and the few that aren't
seldom bear any real relationship to the
reality of being a trial lawyer and I'm
saying that you know f lee Bailey and
Alan Dershowitz and Jerry Spence weren't
brilliant all of the time and didn't
always have winning cases but a book by
somebody whose clients are always
righteous and who has never lost a case
doesn't give a really very clear view of
what most trial lawyers go through in
their careers so despite the that the
terrible reputation at least in my mind
of trial lawyers memoirs I decided that
I would try to write one that might be a
little more realistic a little less
self-important and hopefully give a
little bit more realistic view of what
it's like to become a trial lawyer what
the process is of becoming a trial
lawyer and you know what maybe a little
inside realistic view of that really
important but peculiar institution the
American justice system I hoped I could
also tell some good stories some stories
that people that weren't lawyers but
just like good stories would be
interested in reading and so I sat down
to write this book which incidentally I
have to say it took me a lot longer than
I expected it was a lot more work than I
thought I thought all I can write that
book in about three months but as my
wife Jane will tell you it took a lot
learn and as my editor will tell you it
took a lot longer than than I thought
really the book is divided into two
parts the first couple of chapters are
really chapters that describe the
process of learning to be a trial heir I
think almost every lawyer that you talk
to will tell you that despite the
advances in courses in law school and
trial work and that kind of thing
there's really only one way to learn how
to try cases and that's by trying cases
it is in fact as
title of the book suggests a process of
learning from your mistakes
a process of trial and error and
therefore it is probably appropriate
that the book begins with a scene from
the very first jury case I ever tried
and it will probably be of no surprise
that it was also the first case I ever
lost not I'm sorry to say the last but
it was a an experience that I have never
forgotten because I was appointed to
represent a young man who was accused of
a serious crime and I utterly knew
nothing of of what to do and when he was
convicted as he probably should have
been but he certainly got a poor defense
and his mother who was in the courtroom
when he was sentenced to nine years in
the penitentiary screamed in a way that
I remember to this day and so I made a
resolution that I wasn't going to ever
feel quite so inadequate again and began
the process of learning how to try cases
how to survive in the courtroom and at
the same time how to survive in a law
firm in a big city which is a somewhat
different skill
after that description the book really
kind of proceeds chronologically mostly
chronologically for the first six or
seven years of my practice as a lawyer -
again I help tell some good stories
introduce the readers to some really
interesting people in the Chicago legal
world and to to talk about some of the
problems I had some of the lessons I
learned some of the pitfalls of learning
to be a trial lawyer after I get to the
point where I feel like I have a little
bit of confidence that maybe I know
something about what I'm doing I that
the book really shifts into a series of
chapters that talk about you know
somewhat more details some of the cases
that I tried that some of you may have
heard of or remember or involved people
clients or other lawyers that are
interesting people and and and people
that again you may have heard of them
and and know something about the first
chapter really I think I I wanted to
deal with the subject of justice and
injustice in our court system and in in
the course of doing that I talked about
two cases I had as a fairly young lawyer
one of them involved a person who for
over 25 years had been deprived of
desperately needed psychic psychiatric
help
because of a stupid bureaucratic rule a
catch-22 rule that made it impossible
for him to get that help and was the
help of a then quite young Chicago
psychiatrist by the name of Bernie Rubin
who went on to do some of the most
important work in in dealing with
long-term schizophrenics of anybody in
the in the country with Bernie Reubens
help I was able to get that rule
and to bring at least after all those
years a certain amount of justice to his
situation the other case discussed in
that chapter is a case that my senior
partner Bert Jenner and I became
involved in after a physician had been
accused of failure to file tax returns
this was a orthopedic surgeon who was
literally a saint of a man some of you
might even remember his name his name
was was dr. Gavin and his case became
extremely controversial all over Chicago
and people on the south side of Chicago
in the south suburbs filed literally
thousands of letters and petitions and
so forth because this man had worked
1820 hours a day six or seven days a
week all of his life helping his fellow
man doing a tremendous amount of charity
work and so forth and yet because of a
an ill-advised prosecution and a
despotic judge his life was destroyed
and there was nothing that any of us
could do about it
and the result of that was as I say a
case of injustice because in fact it is
not a perfect system and we have justice
and we have injustice in the system
another case I guess the second case I
talk about in some detail is the famous
Chicago conspiracy seven case that those
of you that are of an age of most of you
in this room will probably remember that
was a case in which my role was was was
very minor but I represented along with
my partner Tom Sullivan a number of the
lawyers who were held in contempt for
that case but as a result I got to know
and observe the case and get to know all
of the defendants and so forth and I
think that the the chapter on that case
probably has some some interesting
stories about things that happened that
haven't ever been told before
and it also I think is perhaps an effort
to put that case into some context at
the time it was sort of the trial of the
century at least of the 60s and 70s that
was the trial of the century and and the
impact that it had on the the cultural
wars that were going on in that period
and the ultimate impact of the case in
really in preserving the First Amendment
freedom of speech when at the despite
the prosecution and the convictions in
that case the courts of appeals
ultimately reversed all of those
convictions and upheld the right of
protest and the right of these people to
protest the war at the Democratic
convention so that's a really
interesting case I think and the people
involved were truly fascinating people
there's another chapter that involves a
case a couple of cases but one in
particular that I tried representing
Madison Square Garden against the then
heavyweight champion Muhammad Ali and in
that case I think I really probably put
it in the book largely because of
Muhammad Ali's name hoping I'd sell a
few books but but but it was really a
fun case because the characters were
right out of Damon Runyon I mean every
witness in the case Don King was a
witness Ali himself was a witness
another fight manager named Eddie Futch
was a witness and and it one after the
other they they were all characters that
you would read about in a Damon Runyon
story and they and their testimony
sometimes was absolutely hilarious so
that's really kind of just a fun chapter
about some people you've heard of and
and maybe it was fun to read because it
the the people themselves were so
interesting after that I I talked about
a number of cases that that actually
occurred over a quite a long period of
the time I was practicing law because I
became involved in quite a number of
cases involving election
and political disputes and one of them
was a case that went up ultimately the
Supreme Court of the United States in
which we were able to establish that
that the patronage system i sued mayor
daley the real mayor daley and we were
we were able to establish that the
system of hiring and firing basic tirely
upon your support of that in that
instance of course the Cook County
Democratic Party was a violation of the
First Amendment and the Supreme Court of
the United States ultimately so held and
it was a fascinating case Tom Horne was
on the other side of it when we argued
it in the Supreme Court and and it was a
wonderful interesting argument
ironically about 15 or 20 years later
the present Mayor Daley and Tom Hines
who was then the Assessor of Cook County
we're having their patronage workers
fired by Jane Byrne because Richie Daley
was going to run for state's attorney
and so Tom Heinsohn Richie Daley hired
me to sue Jane Byrne to enforce the the
law that I had established by suing his
father and I thought that was a lot of
fun and and in fact when I what they
asked me to take the case I looked at
that then the now Mayor Daley had said
you know I really wasn't gonna do these
cases any longer but I can't resist
suing somebody on behalf for patronage
violations on behalf of somebody named
Richard Daley it was irresistible
another chapter involves the case that I
cared the most about of any case I ever
had it was called generally in this city
it was called the contract buyers League
case and it was one of the most
important civil rights cases of the
seventies one of the most controversial
and and some of you may remember it
involved we filed a lawsuit on behalf of
a class consisting of the black
in Chicago who had purchased housing on
contract and had been charged grossly
overcharged for the for the houses as a
result of the the segregation in the in
the housing market in Chicago that made
it possible with the tremendous influx
of blacks in the end of the city to to
overcharge them and it was a case again
that was you know front-page headlines
really for several years as the case
undeveloped and there was some
incredibly wonderful people who were
involved in that case and people that I
think I treasure that experience
probably more than any any case I was
ever involved in despite the fact that
in the end after a very very long trial
we lost the case after that I guess
another chapter involved my
representation of the people who were
alleged to be high up in the so-called
Mafia in Chicago and also in Milwaukee
and a couple of other places I tried a
series of cases for people whose names
ended in vowels and whoever thought that
Little John Tucker you know from North
Shore Country Day School would would be
representing these people some of them
were terrible people but some of them
were absolutely wonderful people and I
talked about two cases that I tried for
the two men who essentially ran sports
gambling in the Midwest one of them was
named Donald Angelini known as The
Wizard of odds and he essentially set
the line for all sports gambling all
over the Midwest and then his partner
and
childhood friend am cartina was the
operating man for for all of the
bookmaking people and they were really I
have to say two of my very favorite
clients they were much more reliable in
what they told you
than a lot of the corporate executives
that I represented their word was as
good as gold if they told you they were
that something had happened it had
happened they never lied to me and they
were delightful delightful men in the
course of representing them I was they
were they were prosecuted by what was
then known as the strikeforce
strikeforce against organized crime and
they had been targeted and as a result
of that that target those target
prosecutions we were able to establish
has happened so often in target
prosecutions that in fact the FBI had
manufactured evidence against them
flat-out lied under oath now and and and
manufactured documents well that kind of
thing is very very very difficult to
prove but we were really fortunate and
we were able to prove it
to to jut to the satisfaction of two
judges one of whom had been a United
States Attorney for many years another
one was had been brought in specially to
try the case from North Dakota an older
judge who had been the judge in Little
Rock Arkansas that that ordered the
federal marshals into Little Rock back
in in the desegregation days and he said
one of the and when he finally ruled
that the that the government had been in
fact guilty of manufacturing evidence
and threw the case out he said well he
said I think the prosecutor said well
well well what about you know what is it
that you think was not true about the
FBI agents testimony and he said well
there was so much of it it's a little
bit to try too hard to say exactly what
I thought if anything was true or
what was untrue but I'll tell you this
if J Edgar Hoover were alive today he'd
be rolling over in his mausoleum and if
he'd heard that man testify so that case
really all of the cases that I've talked
about it here in addition to I hope
being good stories involve lessons that
I learned along the along the line of my
practice and and one of them one of the
lessons from from those cases was the
problem of target prosecutions of and we
saw that later on in the star Clinton
situation then which resulted really
finally in the in the ending what both
the Republicans and Democrats realized
that things had gone to fire and they
ended the special prosecutor law and as
my wife reminded me today in in a sense
we're seeing the same thing now and I'm
sure all of you have read the or not
read the report but read in the papers
in the last few days of the Inspector
General the Justice Department's report
about the FBI problems in in the
terrorism investigations and when you
get I mean of course nobody could
possibly argue that we have to fight
terrorism but when you get to the point
where you have the FBI or the the
agencies that are involved so determined
to get somebody that they began
manufacturing evidence then then our
system is in grave danger and I think
that's a really important lesson finally
I guess the last chapter is a short
chapter in which I briefly I assure you
briefly pontificate on the subject of
our system of justice and and the
practice of law generally does the book
succeed in avoiding the problems of the
genre that I described at the beginning
I suspect that I am NOT the person to
make that judgment I will say that the
reviewers have been very kind so far
the reviews have been good and in fact
my favorite review I will quote to you a
portion of it Perkis lee the
pre-publication reviewers called the
book an eminently instructive guide for
law students and lawyers and for general
readers an authentic version of a world
they normally see only through the
meretricious lens of TV courtroom dramas
well that may be a little extreme but I
hope that it is something like that and
I hope that all of you if you have an
opportunity to read the book will agree
thanks very much for coming I'm really
there's so many old friends here that I
haven't seen for a long time that I've
just astounded and I want to see you all
after this I'll ask answer any questions
that you have and then when I'm done if
any of you have been kind enough to buy
the book I'll sit down someplace and
sign it and if you will tell me the
nicest thing you can think of you'd like
me to say I'll say it in the in the
court any questions I have a question
yes did you ever clean up your office
now that was an unfair question Ken
Burns used to be one of my law partners
and no I didn't there was you may recall
though Kenny at the time that I said I
was gonna leave the practice the Jim
mournfulness from the Tribune who was
their legal ready to wrote a long
article about how unusual it was for
somebody to leave at my age and so forth
in position and they came over from the
Tribune and took a picture of me that
ran the paper the next day and it had an
industrial-sized wastebasket next to my
desk because I was starting to clean
things out and they'd had to bring you
know I dumpster in
probably should have been there the
whole time right Ken
yes sir John based on your long
experience what is your view on how
successful a jury system is and
particularly in handling a very
complicated technical cases but also in
other cases where it's mostly emotional
I'm a great believer in the jury system
and by saying that I don't mean to say
that I think that they always get it
right because they don't and of course
you hear all kinds of horror stories but
the horror stories that you hear
particularly and you know enormous
verdicts and that people think are
ridiculous they seldom tell you that
those cases were almost always reversed
or the huge verdicts cut way back I
don't know you know I guess what I would
say would be the paraphrase Churchill
about democracy it's the worst system
there is except every other systems and
that's the way I feel about it anybody
else can that comment about the Martha
Stewart situation targeted prosecution
well I don't I don't really cuz I don't
know anything about the facts of the
case I will say that I if in fact as
I've read in the newspaper one of the
charges is that it was a violation of
securities laws for her to say I didn't
do it because that moved her stock price
I think that's a ludicrous concept now
whether she obstructed justice or not in
lying to the FBI agents and so forth
which is a crime I think he's a
different question and that's something
that he may have a big problem with yes
John they brought something just brought
it from earth still a case for what
about all these other corporate mrs.
Adventures that you might say they don't
seem to be able to have indicted any of
those SOPs yet well yeah that's
interesting you say that because my wife
was just complaining about
the other day and I first of all I think
they have indicted a number of people
and and they're going to indict a whole
lot more but these are very complicated
cases the law is frequently not I mean
this is not like murder or armed robbery
there are these are very complicated
cases and they're really to prove the
knowledge and intent of the highest
people the people that we're all waiting
to get indicted they're basically
working their way up the chain and that
is the way prosecutions in complicated
cases work they get some of the lower
guys that they can prove the case
against with direct evidence they indict
them they either convict them or make a
deal with them to testify about two
people the next line up and they work up
and I will I will confidently predict
you that for example that Ken Lay is
going to get indicted you may not have
been indicted yet but he's gonna get
indicted yes Carol how often do you wish
you were back in the courtroom never no
that's not true I really loved trying
cases but I from the time I was
graduated from college I made a kind of
a vow to myself that I wanted to spend
part of my time writing and thanks to my
wife I've had that opportunity and so I
don't regret it at all very poor this
year is I was in Hawaii you know I had I
didn't have a chance
yes ray John can you comment a now or
did you in the book on your relation
with opposing counsel in these various
matters I the reason for my question is
I see some of the younger attorneys
today that look at a litigated dispute
is Jenner and block against Sun and
shiner against Sidley or say and the
lawyers are battling the lawyers and for
getting about the issue that's it's up
it's a case about the client really did
you have you know respectful and cordial
relations there absolutely and and I
mean obviously there were exceptions to
that but that this of course we all have
well this is one of the real major
controversies in the profession now and
you know sometimes it's overstated I
think but when I was practicing law
basically the lawyers on the other side
for the most part were my friends and
you know when the case was over you went
out and you had a drink and
congratulated each other or whatever and
respected each other and it's hard
enough to try cases without turning it
into a pissing contest if you'll excuse
me and I do think that happens more now
and I don't know what can be done about
it the pressures of I guess you know
when when at any cost and they have have
turned it into it I think a more of a
jungle and that's really unfortunate but
I for me to say that it's really almost
unfair I hear them but I haven't you
know I haven't tried a case against
another lawyer to verdict in 18 years so
you know it's really more hearsay than
anything else let's talk about writing
john are you writing again and what are
you writing are you going to write
another book about the law or something
else yeah actually if you look at
yesterday's USA Today there's a an op-ed
piece that I wrote about the Michigan
affirmative action case but so I like to
write short things from time to time but
I am researching another book and it is
gonna be if I succeed in in getting the
cooperation I need to write the story it
will be another book about essentially
about the criminal justice system and
about a very really extraordinary series
of murder cases that I think
we'll create a book that really is much
wider than just a true-crime border but
I don't know that that'll work it
depends on some cooperation that I
haven't figured out yet but I've got a
I'm gonna keep writing absolutely and
probably mostly about legal subjects
because that's what I know the most
about sounds like you you think in
ethical terms that you want to bring the
Essex back to the legal profession is
that so or well I I'm not sure that
ethics has really ever left the
profession but I certainly do think
that's important I think ethics is
extremely important and you know lawyer
it's it's kind of energy lawyers have
always had a terrible reputation you
know I mean they're like congressmen
everybody hates congressmen except their
own congressmen and everybody hates
lawyers except their own lawyers and two
or three years ago and and and of course
lawyers there they feel terrible about
this in there we're always trying to
find ways to make people like us you
know and you know and trying how did we
get this awful image and what can we do
about it
not sure this is I'm not sure I haven't
wandered off though your question but I
do have to say that I I had a really
funny experience about four or five
years ago I was going through some
papers that I had that had been belonged
to my father who was a lawyer and who
had graduated from law school I think in
1926 or something like that would that
be right patty something close to that
and there was a speech in these papers
that he had written in 1928 and the
speech was about how can we get people
to like lawyers
so yeah it hasn't changed and I don't
think it'll ever change you know we're
in a profession where we represent
clients and the people you know on the
other side don't like us and they think
they read these terrible things but I
think it's a wonderful profession and
I'm very glad I was part of it okay this
is a follow-up question you're very glad
you were part of it you had a an amazing
career one of your reviewers said that
it would be impossible in the 21st
century for anyone to have a career like
the one that you had do you think that
that's right well and and and the reason
that the reasons that he gave for that
were reasons that everybody is concerned
about the tremendous emphasis that there
has developed on the bottom line lawyers
making huge amounts of money and
insisting that the young associates work
you know 22 or 2300 hours a year on
paying matters lawyers skipping from one
firm to another the lack of a cohesive
group of partners who will say to each
other yeah let John go off and do a pro
bono case for the contract buyers League
and even though we cost a million
dollars in time and so forth let young
lawyers learn how to try cases by trying
small cases even though the fees aren't
there or even though they may be pro
bono cases and I don't know what the
answer to that is fewer and fewer cases
are being tried maybe it would be
impossible I I probably did do more pro
bono work than almost anybody would get
away with today in a big law firm on the
other hand I just we had a wonderful
reception for me at Jenner & black my
old law firm on on Wednesday night and a
number of the younger partners and the
younger lawyers there are still trying
pro bono criminal cases which is where I
cut my teeth I think the time will only
tell I worry about it a lot because
I do believe that it's becoming every
year more and more a business and less
and less a profession and and as that
happens then we will deserve the scorn
of of the public yeah you know I see
lawyers charging hourly rates for their
time that are just unbelievable I mean
you just can't an ordinary person can't
afford to hire a lawyer from a big law
firm anymore so I I don't know but I did
it is a big question I think I else well
again thanks so much for being here and
John Tucker's book trial-and-error the
education of a courtroom lawyer is
published by Carroll & Graf online at
Carroll & Graf com